Wow now how do you how do you do that
and me like it's chill a lot of other
people have been doing their own spin on
professionals reacting to things related
to their line of work now we're a bunch
of visual effects artists and today
we're going to react to deceased actors
one of the most challenging things you
can do on visual effects is make a photo
realistic human look completely normal
[Music]
in terms of trying to replicate a person
that no longer is alive this is the best
that has ever been done so this is the
one shot that most people identify as
the fake Paul Walker they didn't do any
sort of computer-generated face here
this is actually old footage from
another movie that was composited meshed
back onto his face and real it's ah the
only thing that gives it away is if you
watched his neck in the collar of his
shirt the way his body moves doesn't
correspond to how his head is moving
like his body shifts back which would
naturally cause your head to like rock a
little bit and that doesn't happen his
eyeline it looks like he's looking way
past yeah yeah camera he's not making
eye contact with Vin Diesel it looks
like he's just staring off into the
business like his eyes are also like
super sharp like that this is like
stripped right here is the clarity is
really high and I don't think it really
matches the clarity of like down his
chin and shirt this is the shot that
everyone really recognizes is the fake
Paul Walker but there are dozens of
shots throughout this whole movie where
Paul Walker was completely
computer-generated from like the neck
line up what they actually have Paul
Walker's brothers they look like him
just enough that they use it as
inspiration for the performance and
reference for the lighting whoa because
they actually replace from neckline up
the brothers with Paul Walker's
computer-generated face mm-hmm this
entire scene Paul Walker's face is fake
what that's good it's really good that's
really good yeah I had no idea it's such
a normal situation so it doesn't trigger
anything to be looking for the effects
that's crazy well this looks really good
I don't really good the only thing that
slightly puts it off is the the chin in
the neck with the collar like the
shadows and like you can see his brother
this folds there as it goes like this
they don't quite have those folds with
Paul walk
you don't really notice it you know it
really stands out to me the iris is in
the eyes so your iris and your lens are
like different levels and so when light
comes in from the side of your eye it
catches your iris a little bit so that
means that the artists have modeled the
internals of the eye and the iris has
actual depth in the eye eyes are the
portal into the soul and people have
worked for years trying to perfect
rendering eyes this one looks a little
CJ's I don't think working that shot
this is where the uncanny valley comes
in it's really hard to identify what
exactly is off here but our brain after
millions of years of evolving to
identify faces can identify that
something is off there I mean this right
here is just a demonstration of how good
it actually is and I can't point out
that that would sounds perfect that
looks perfect man yeah they have the
cheek muscles flex like watch in a
second here once it splits whoa yeah
they're like it punches his job as cheek
flexes what a digital is probably the
most talented visual effects studio in
the world
in terms of trying to replicate a person
that no longer is alive this is the best
that has ever been done wrong supposed
to go away alone so Lee Bullock I say
whoa oh oh I have seen this whoa
G yeah it feels wrong dude this is like
Tekken 7 right here dude he's too gummy
he's too like oh I can't help but think
that Bruce Lee wouldn't be cool if
somebody using his corpse to sell
alcohol I don't think they nailed the
subsurface scattering that's what I was
gonna say - his skin looks - plasticky
or waxy if we had a flashlight here I'd
show you he was here though do it on the
back of my ears you know what I'm
talking about where your skin lights up
kind of like red that happens across
your face your arm it absorbs light and
scatters it the skin itself is actually
kind of self illuminating and here it
definitely looks like they didn't really
nail that subsurface scattering effect
so it kind of comes across as like it's
just a reflective plastics in your face
towards me a little bit so I can see
yeah you gotta lighten my eyes I know
just keep it closed now on the tip of
his nose
what's happening is the lights actually
going in and then scattering a little
bit coming back out and if there's light
coming from this side and there's shadow
on this side right on the edge where the
light meets the shadow of your skin and
it leads to a slightly reddish like edge
between the skin where it's bright and
where it's dark and look at the edge of
his nose and his brow and his eyelid and
there's cheek there's none of that
slightly reddish
that little reddish line there's the
perfect example of that red line of
subsurface scattering this is it like
that's what I'm talking about where it's
not about to single to see through
things it's also riding the edge of
where the light disappears because you
have a little bit that light that's
actually gotten into the surface that's
now catching that that shadow right
there if you want it to be real
especially when you do high key lighting
like this you need to model that and
that's very complicated because you get
into your skeleton underneath your face
it's gonna block all the light since
we've all got they each either me it is
though it is he looks like that one guy
from Tekken that looked a lot better
this one right here because because
you're hiding detail you know you're
you're you're kind of hiding it but in
the other ones is like you have you go
real extreme on the lighting it does a
lot to hide your flaws hey ma come on
okay wait I've never watched The
Sopranos I want to see if I can identify
who's replacing you've never seen The
Sopranos
who's CG the chair mammy it's her
brothers gotta be the oldest one sitting
in a chair yeah yeah yeah I see the
ambient occlusion around the neck yeah
Graham Enix is hovering it's a hover
head it's a totally different color pop
her head is a big problem
just watch flickin Civil War and like
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner their heads
on those suits yeah now look there's no
shadow between them and it's like the
the softness in sharpness don't match
also her shoulders not casting a shadow
on her neck what happened dude what
where's that bright light yeah it's not
letting up her shoulders out let me
upper arm on the side of the chair just
the side of her face I told her this is
what we mean when we say match the
lighting of the shot you're gonna do
before actually shooting a green-screen
elements oh this is unmotivated lighting
right dude they said don't move when you
act just stance down don't move your
shoulders or your head
how do you how do you do that and be
like it's chill
the lighting chain that thought that the
dude of the frickin light yeah the other
side what happened just then Wow
I'm sure there's nothing that people
could do it's like they got given the
footage like slap it on the face now her
parts on the right side you're so right
dude they Corazon ttle flipped it Mouse
on the left side horizontal why would
they even flip it between those two
shots and that E they had to it looks
like they were just using was given
maybe they knew she was gonna pass
so like real quick let's swoop in throw
the green screen up get the pop out
green screen by her hospital bed maybe
no I don't think imagine that's you and
you're like I'm feeling pretty good
today and the producer comes up so we
think you're gonna die soon so you want
shoot some pickup shots before you go
I'm just gonna get all your emotional
you'll feel good today
I think the only person you can get away
doing that with is Stan Lee I have a
feeling you're right Ren like it's it be
chill to go up and saying lame be like
yo let me gather those assets before you
know we're also making a lot of
assumptions here we are
it seems you one new freak you in danger
of becoming a good man
in the gladiator movie where an actor
dies before the movie finishes
production and they still have scenes to
shoot with him so this is Oliver Reed
the actor what's his name is that
próximo is that his name so I say so
they took him for that one shot and put
them into this shot
basically it's just a collage cutting it
out of one shot sticking into the other
and like giving a little color change
video Photoshop okay are they gonna be
there with ya oh they have the
production design they did it oh that's
that's smart that's really smart that's
that's going like all right we have this
crazy lighting on his face let's design
our set for this extra steam you gotta
get so it can motivate the same shadows
dude the freaking criss cross that's
what the Sopranos needed that's that's
flawless the simplest way to do it is
the most effective right here
grandma Tarkin it's not grandma grandma
tark have you ever seen Star Wars so
Peter Cushing is the actor who died some
time ago and the only reason why they
were able to reproduce him digitally in
this movie was because they actually had
a perfect life cast of his face Wow and
they just that was just pure luck on
their part and so they're able to take a
very high detailed 3d scan of that
casting of his face to recreate them
digitally the lighting is great the
lighting is very good they're doing all
the things I'm saying with Lighting's
like a strong side key light good
contrast they've got the good subsurface
scattering on his skin all the technical
checklists are being checked off here
but why doesn't it look why doesn't it
look that good cuz I actually I think it
looks really bad in my opinion I think
it really stands out well no I do too
it's like too floaty it's too free
elation it's the most read the lips for
me the motion of the lips is the hardest
thing to do cuz I don't know there's so
many intricate ways your lips can move
and it's really hard to replicate that
digitally everything else looks pretty
solid but you can always tell you can
tell that it's not real it's like an
animated and gummy lip it's just it's
hard to say what have they not yet done
to take it to that final step this is
basically the best we can do while still
being in the uncanny valley it's so good
it's so good but you can still tell and
I don't know what to do to make it
better I think the problem isn't how
good it looks when it's still because
clearly it looks perfect yeah how good
it looks when it's moving it's the small
things that happen in your face when big
things happen like when I go ahh you
know the big thing is my jaw opens up
and you see that the small things that
happen are my hairs change directions my
poor is stretched the plates of my skin
like stretching to get micro wrinkles
really in depth physics like the soft
body meet physics sounds like your face
which is very complicated that's where I
think grand moff tarkin is failure it's
just very firm he has like the skin
firmness like a 25 year old yeah a 25
year old who hasn't eaten anything in
two weeks if someone asked me to do this
I wouldn't know where to start
it'd be like the equivalent of like
someone banging hey I need you to go out
the desert and like put all these little
pieces of sand in order what is it
they've sent us
how again this looks very very good but
it does not look real but it doesn't
look real when it was wide it looked
really good and then like she got so
close to the camera he could literacy
like the makeup texture for like her
eyes were like which is impressive they
had that detail that's like Roy this is
hyper sharpen high resolution it's the
animation of the lips that's the best
thing in that shot I look pretty good to
me though between the nose and above the
chin this strip right here yeah the shot
just kind of confounds me her eyes kind
of look wrong the reason her eyes lack
soul is because she's not giving the
performance people aren't just their
physical manifestation themselves it's
also the personality this is somebody
trying to pretend they're Carrie Fisher
this isn't Carrie Fisher regardless of
how much it looks like Carrie Fisher I'm
gonna show you guys something and see
what you guys think tell me what you
looks better or worse what is it they've
sent us hope that looks better the
contrast is wow that looks way better
[Music]
natural performance yeah one of the far
right is what they matched her to that
was when she's confronting lord Vader at
the very beginning of a new hope
look how her lip pulls out just a little
bit more in the middle the intricacy in
the nuance and I'm also there where
these muscles are pushing up and this
one's pulling out leading to a little
more of a pronounced curve that you
don't have in the motion-captured robe
one version yeah that looks way better
oh my god that looks way better
yeah emotion that nailed the motion so
this is a question for you guys and for
you guys I'd love to hear your comments
do you believe people should own the
likeness of their face because
theoretically I can stick Tom Cruise in
a corridor video right now or at least
something that looks like Tom Cruise I
won't be able to say it's Tom Cruise the
town cruise because I would be lying but
I can have something that looks exactly
like Tom Cruise should he get upset can
he sue me for his likeness do we own our
muscular structure of our faces it's
definitely a gray line there's a skill
and a talent acting it's more than just
how you look
I love reacting these videos trying to
explain all these techniques exactly if
you have a movie a TV show a music video
that you want us to break down leave a
comment below we had a bunch of great
suggestions we've made a huge list so
far and we are going through we're gonna
knock them out so please leave a comment
we read them all Oh
I have a video for you guys to see next
it's one that we did recently it's
really cool and involves a motion
capture suit and transforming Clint tell
me about the video check this out
challenge these guys can you transform
from Optimus Prime into a truck and
actually drive down the freeway wait
what do you mean can you can you contort
your body in a motion capture suit link
it up to a model of Optimus Prime and
look like a truck you don't look like a
rocket
can't be done I guess you'll have to
watch the video to find out